why do you think you've been so
criticized by so many progressives one
interesting thing is there seems to be
one San Democrat and I cannot believe
this this man deserves an award I would
like to send this man an award the one
sane Democrat is the senator from
Pennsylvania the guy that we all thought
had brain damage has turned out to be
the one saane Democrat it's wild yes
it's John fedman making
sense because obviously a lot of
progressive on Twitter have been
attacking you for your position on
Israel uh for noting that in your
opinion um saying that there is a crisis
at the border does not make one uh
xenophobic um why do you think you've
been so criticized by so many
progressives I I honestly don't
understand I I don't understand why it's
controversial to anybody to decide that
you're going to stand with Israel in
this situation I honestly don't
understand why it's controversial to say
we we need a secure border uh and I
think two things can be true at the same
time you can be very supportive of
immigration but we also need to have a
secure border and I really I think about
immigration is we want to provide the
American dream for any migrant but it
seems very difficult when you have
300,000 people showing up in counter at
at our quarter to do that and I think we
need to to re do a reset and we have to
work together uh and develop uh a new
comprehensive solution to that John
fedan is like the movie Awakenings do
you guys see the movie Awakening
remember it's Robert dairo and and Robin
Williams is the doctor and they start he
dairo is in like a coma and they put him
on this experimental medication and he
sort and he comes back to life and he's
he's okay again fman when he sort of had
brain damage was a progressive now he's
getting out of that like whatever
happened to him medically he's getting
out of that and he's becoming a
conservative it's a freaking Miracle but
okay fedman calling out his own side now
it's interesting he keeps saying I don't
really understand it now I think we've
laid out a case over the last 45 minutes
or so that there is a way to understand
what these people are doing that they
are Marxist they don't like our freedoms
they don't like individual choice they
don't like America they don't like our
founding all those things I think
Federman ironically will get there it
seems like he is on his way and and
we'll see how he becomes an aema to the
to the rest of the party as the party
goes off the deep
end